i want to thank you because your workout
videos motivated me oh yeah because wow
i would in a good way okay i'm down like
listen
i'm down 25 pounds right now
and i was like man if this guy could be
in the studio all night and then go to
the gym every [ __ ] day uh this is
when you were like going crazy on reels
like
ten times a day yeah yeah see ya um
thank you man but uh dude i've been
working and i've also taken note i've
been working out on my draws in my
garage every [ __ ] day way better
right yeah you don't have these heavy
shorts bouncing around it's just freedom
you know what i'm saying yeah
free from all trends uh
more workout videos coming for the
summer you know i had to take a little
break just so people would miss them and
there was some crazy interviews like i
would hear like women talking about me
and like a wild-ass way i was like whoa
uh well you are out here you know listen
you know what i'm saying i mean you know
that wasn't the goal i was i understand
that wasn't that literally trying to
show my workout right i happen to be
comfortable with myself
so showing the workout while showing the
prince a little extra extra yeah
for those who care about that but you
know uh more workouts coming for the
summer because yeah we're trying we
getting shredded on tour uh i got some
new [ __ ] that i want people to tap into
and i'm hella happy that you know that
[ __ ] with you and you
he's like you know what i'm did
saying cause there'd be times where i'd
be like i'd see you the night before
yeah and i'd be like damn we were
just raging and the next morning you're
like yeah no i love that [ __ ] dawg like
i'm still gonna be doing it on the road
every night
we're gonna freaking rage and then i'm
gonna be up in the morning in my draws
working out what is your regiment like
is it how many times a week do you have
to work out five days a week so five
days a week and then how do you break
the days down is it like arms shoulders
we can get technical so monday is leg
day tuesday is chest
and a little bit of shoulders uh
wednesday is back then we go right back
to legs and then we do chest and then we
do back again um yeah yeah and the
biceps and triceps just fall in there
because yeah well we do like multiple
blocks so it's like you know we might do
a little bit of uh pushing like real
heavy [ __ ] and then we might do some
just some functional [ __ ] and then throw
a little bit of biceps in there for some
pump and some some try some kickbacks
some you know some [ __ ] uh skull
crushers like there's all different
types of [ __ ] to do that aren't like
your normal
heavy lifting but they still get the job
done so we just mix all of that stuff in
there do you ever see old videos and old
pictures of yourself when you were like
skinny ass whiz with you you got one of
the craziest metabolisms of all time
clearly uh but like and you're just like
god damn bro
because you were skinniest it's
sickening bro like i'd be like that's
gross i'll be like get that footage out
of there this is the you know what i
mean because
there's lifestyle change that goes with
that so when you see that person not
that person but when you see yourself uh
not at your best or on your way to your
best
you don't really look at that in the
best way like for me i
love the transformation but it's how i
feel and it's mentally a transformation
as well like i can't live without the
gym so back then i wasn't thinking about
you know waking up and working out or
eating correctly or you know weighing
myself and making sure that i'm at the
appropriate weight for you know what i
mean like i wasn't doing none of that
[ __ ] so the mind frame
it wasn't you know like food wise you
just eating a bunch of proteins i ate
everything i want to um i could have
burgers if i got that metabolism i love
raising canes i just got to make sure i
get a bunch of uh calories in that's the
main thing it's like getting the the
right amount of calories and i eat a lot
of fruits and vegetables because i want
to gain the right type of way i don't
want to just be like you know big and
[ __ ] constipated
like so yeah